في رومانيا فاجا رئيس الوزراء
نيكولايسيوكا الحضور في اجتماع الحكومه
بتعيين عضو جديد هذا العضو هو روبوتس
وباتا في منصب مستشار اكلت اليه مهمه فك
رموز الشبكات الاجتماعيه
ايون هو اسم المستشار الجديد وجرى تطويره
من باحثين من جامعات عده في رومانيا التي
توصف بانها وادي السليكن في اوروبا شرقيه
سيعمل على ابلاغ الحكومه بمقترحات
الرومانيين ورغباتهم من خلال التحليل
المشهورات الاكثر انتشارا على الشبكات
الاجتماعيه والدردشه مع المواطنين وبعد
الحديث شدد رئيس الوزراء الروماني على ان
الاقتناع باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي ينبغي
الا يكون خيارا بل واجبا لاتخاذ قرارات
مستمره بشكل افضل
نعود بكم لعقدين ماضيين ونبحث في السؤال
كيف تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي ليصل الى
مزاحمتنا حتى على وظائفنا هند ابراهيم
قد يغيب عن ذلك انك قبل 20 عاما لم تتخيل
حتى امتلاك هاتف ذكي ولم يكن يخطر على
بالك انك بنقره واحده يمكنك الاطلاع على
حياه اصدقاء وغرباء يبعدون عنك الاف
الكيلومترات فقبل عشرين عاما لم يكن هناك
ايفون
او انستقرام او فيسبوك او يوتيوب او
نتفليكس او اليكسا او سيري او تشات جي بي
تي او تسلا والقائمه تطول فجميعنا يعرف ان
الحياه البشريه بعد نهضه الذكاء الاصطناعي
ليست هي كما كانت قبله
[موسيقى]
تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي على نحو متسارع في
العقدين الماضيين جراء استخدام تقنيات
ابرزها ما يعرف باسم التعليم الالي اي
قدره الالات الذكيه على تعليم نفسها عن
طريق مراجعه كميات هائله من البيانات ومن
التعليم الالي ما يوصف بالتعليم العميق
الذي صمم ليعمل مثل الشبكات العصبيه في
الدماغ البشري
مع التعليم العميق اصبح الذكاء الاصطناعي
اقرب الى الذكاء الطبيعي اثبات يصعب
التمييز ان كان محدثك الافتراضي مثل شات
جي بي تي اله من الخوارزميات ام انسانا
سويا فهو قادر على كتابه المقالات
والابحاث والشعر واضحى مثار جدل في
الجامعات والمدارس الامريكيه التي منع
بعضها استخدامه لانه يقوم بالواجبات نيابه
عن الطلاب
[موسيقى]
وفيما يستبشر المعنيون في عده مجالات
كالصحه والصناعه والتكنولوجيا خيرا بتطوير
الذكاء الاصطناعي يخشى كثيرون في الولايات
المتحده من استيلاء الاله الذكيه على
الوظائف او من استخدامه لاختراق الخصوصيه
او لنشر معلومات مضلله او فيديوهات مزيفه
او استخدامه كاداه للمراقبه عبر برامج
التعرف على الوجه وهو امر استدعى حكومات
عده مدن امريكيه عام 2019 الى حظر استخدام
هذه التكنولوجيا
الولايات المتحده مقر اهم شركات
التكنولوجيا تفتقر الى قواعد مكثفه تحكم
كيفيه نشر الذكاء الاصطناعي الامر الذي
يرى خبراء انه سيكون الفاصله لضمان
استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل امن وهناك
ايضا من يحذر من يوم يتمكن فيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي من اخذ زمام المبادره من البشر
لكن هذا ضربا من دروب الخيال العلمي حتى
الان لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم واشنطن
الرهان يرتفع بشكل كبير على الذكاء
الاصطناعي بين شركات التكنولوجيا للحفاظ
على صدرتها اظهر تحليل اجراه مركز انتر
ريجينال الى انه من دون الاهتمام بهذا
القطاع قد تتمكن بعض الشركات الناشئه
بمفردها او بتمويل من شركات تكنولوجيه
اخرى من تقديم ابتكارات جديده تهدد عمالقه
التكنولوجيا وفقا للبيانات تحديدا عام
2021 بلغت قيمه الاستثمارات في شركات
تطوير عمليات الذكاء الاصطناعي ثلاثه عشر
مليار دولار وضعت شركه مايكروسوفت ما
يتراوح بين عشره مليارات وعشرين مليار
دولار في شركه اوبن اي واطلقت الشركه
برنامج اي اي فور ايرث لحمايه الكوكب من
التغيرات المناخيه
شركه ميتا طورت حاسوبا عملاقا يعمل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي وهو الحاسوب الذي قد
يكون الاسرع عالميا شركه ابل استحوذت على
شركات متخصصه بهدف تطوير مساعدها المعروف
باسم سيري عملاق البحث الصيني ايضا شركه
بايدو كثف استثماراته في مجال السيارات
الذاتيه القياده واطلق شركه
مراقبه ذكيه تتعقب حوادث المرور والسيارات
المتوقفه بشكل غير قانوني
[موسيقى]
ينورنا في الاستوديو دكتور محمد عبد
الظاهر رئيس التنفيذي لمؤسسه صحافه الذكاء
الاصطناعي للبحث والاستشراف دكتور منورنا
في الاستوديو شكرا على تواجد معانا اليوم
طيب دكتور هناك ابحاث الابتكارات
كمبيوترات حيويه تكون مدعومه بخلايا
الدماغ البشري الى تطور قد يكون ثوريا في
مجال الذكر لانه هناك تطور شديد في الهيوم
البشري او اللي هو مكس بين يعني مثلا لو
نظرنا الى ارقام عالميه دلوقتي حاليا يصل
سوق الروبوتس العالمي يعني متوقعا خلال 10
سنين القادمين يصل الى حوالي 70 مليار
دولار لو تتخيلي نصف القيمه دي حوالي 29.
مثلا 5 هو ده قيمه الروبوت البشري روبوت
البشري زي نادين زي مثلا جي جي زي صوفيا
زي الليت صوفيا اللي هي بتجمع المهارات
بعض المهارات البشريه مع مهارات الذكاء
الاصطناعي
[ضحك]
صوفيا الاشياء اللي بتكون مهارات حاليا
انا اتوقع ان الفتره القادمه او الشات
واخواته في كثير من التقنيات شبيهه
في
الفرق هيبقى كبير جدا كبير جدا في الوظائف
في السوق لو اتكلمنا مثلا عن سوق انا
بسميه القوى الروبوتيه سوق القوى العامله
الروبوتيه اللي هو الروبوتيكس
مثلا سوق الذكاء الاصطناعي بوجه عام اكثر
من 70 مليار دولار او شيء
الذكاء الاصطناعي الروبوتس جزء بسيط منه
لان تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي كلها
ابليكيشن اكثر دلوقتي العالم يستخدم اكثر
من نصف مليار تطبيق من تطبيقات الذكاء
الاصطناعي في روبوتس ظاهري هاردوير تقدر
تشوفه اللي احنا بنشوفه صوفيا واخلاله وفي
روبوتس خفي حاجات خفيه تسيطر على
التطبيقات دي برضه لها سوق ضخم جدا واصبحت
في تطور شديد دكتور محمد يعني احنا شفنا
صار في مستشار حكومي
بفعل ذكاء الاصطناعي ينتخيل عم بجمع شكاوى
الناس والمواطنين من السوشيال ميديا
وبيقدر يضبط الموضوع اليوم قديه احنا في
مجالات معينه بنقدر فعلا نستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي ووين الحد وين الحد هو الحد في
ظل التطور الهائل والمتسارع كل يوم في
تقنيات الصناعي مفيش حد ثانيا موضوع
مستشار هو في النهايه انا شايف ان هو مجرد
ديكور ان هو لان رومانيا بالذات هي
رومانيا تخيلوا مثلا عندهم سوق البرمجيات
في رومانيا حاليا يصل حوالي 12 مليار
دولار في دوله كلها 18 مليون نسمه فهما بس
نوع لان هم بيدعموا الاستراتيجيه
الذكيه الصناعي بتاع الدوله فهو مجرد
ديكور حاليا لكن ايه من نوعيه الاستشارات
اللي بياديها ما فيش انا شايف ان الصين
قدمت نماذج من الوظائف بتاعه للصناعه مثلا
تخيلوا فيه روبوت وظائف بيعالج المدمنين
يقدمون نصائح
ان هو يتحدث عن الروبوت وليس عن الذكاء
الصناعي كتطبيقات بالنسبه يعني لفتتني
عباره الايدي العامله الروبوتيه بين
الايدي العامله الروبوتيه والايدي العامله
البشريه لمن ستكون الرياضه وفي اي وظائف
فكل اكثر مهارات الشخص اللي يطور نفسه
هيقدر يسيطر على بوت يعني انت حضرتك مثال
بزميلتنا في الاستوديو ممكن يحل محلها لا
هي لو طورتنا بمهاراتها هي ممكن تقود
اربعه خمسه يشتغلوا تحت ايديها فهي تطوير
المهارات لكن انت لو انت فضلت عالق في
مهاراتك القديمه احنا بنسميها الدينامي
لازم يبقى عندك يعني في المهارات بتاعتك
لو سبت هتفضل روابط هيحل محلك بلا شك طيب
دكتور محمد ما مدى دقه الذكاء الاصطناعي
في الحكم على البشر لانه لما بنحكي عن
مستشار حكومي وصار كمان محامي وقاضي بفعل
الذكاء الاصطناعي يعني ممكن انه يظلم نوعا
اذا البشر احنا بنظلم بعض ما بالك روبوت
قد ايه دقه حضرتك جاوبتي في نفس في نفس
السياق يعني سؤالك البشر بذنوبوا بعض فما
بالك في الروبوت هيظلم ويظلم ويظلمه 10
مرات لانه في النهايه بيعتمد على مدخلات
بشريه انا بدخل فيه الداتا المعينه ده قد
ايه ابتكار كام نسبه ابتكار دلوقتي لا
تتعدى مثلا 10% هنشوف انشات اه بيفتكر
حاجات بس معتمده على داتابيز
من فترات يمكن في بعض الاسئله دي من 21 مش
هاقدر اجاوب بعد 21 ففي على مدى المدخلات
اللي جوه الروبوت ايه
الذكري الصناعي يقال ان البشر يستخدم واحد
في المئه اليوم البحر الذكاء الاصطناعي هل
سيكون البشره المستقبلا اكثر استخداما
واعتمادا على الذكاء الاصطناعي كتطبيقات
وروبوت البشر حاليا متوجهين زي ما سلفت
ذكرا حول الثوره الصناعيه الخامسه هنا دمج
بين المهارات البشريه والمهارات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لا يمكن لي الذكاء الاصطناعي
السيطره على سوق العمل بوجه كامل بدون
تحرك بشري لان البشر هم من يحددون
القطاعات هم من يحددون المهارات التي
يحتاجها من روبوت هم الذين يحددون يصنعون
روبوت سواء كان سوفت وير او هاردوير هم
اللي فلابد ان هناك ان كنت في المهارات
البشريه والمهارات الروبوتيه في المستقبل
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور محمد عبد
الظاهر رئيس التنفيذي لمؤسسه صحافه ذكاء
الاصطناعي البحث والاستشراف شكرا نورتنا
شكرا لك